the long-awaited sequel to guardians of
the galaxy revisited everything fans
loved about the first film while moving
the story forward in a wild and
imaginative way and critics and
audiences alike agree that it was one of
Marvel's most fun movies today and yet
even in an all together terrific
follow-up there is still some weird plot
holes quirky Easter eggs and continuity
questions that left us scratching our
heads while the end credits world yeah
it's all small potatoes compared to the
movies winning qualities but here are
all the dumb things from guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 that left us feeling a
little unsettled star-lords tracking
device from his outfit to his
entertainment system star-lord is all
about the 80s including when it comes to
the tech he whips out in this opening
scene this vintage Mattel football video
game has been rewired to work as a
tracking device but where did it come
from there are only two options one that
quill stumbled upon it during his
travels around the galaxy which would be
a weird coincidence to say the least
or two maybe he had it on him when he
was kidnapped from the earth as a kid
but unlike his Walkman he wasn't too
sentimental about this toy to repurpose
it into a useful piece of tech why are
the Guardians doing the sovereigns dirty
work this big action set piece pitting
the Guardians against a space monster
known as an Abba Liske was such an
amazing scene you can almost ignore the
obvious question why were the Guardians
there in the first place the sovereign
leader offers a reason we could not risk
the lives of our own sovereign citizens
but they wouldn't have to as we find out
shortly they own an entire fleet of
remote-controlled ships that seemed
perfectly equipped for a job like this
what prompted them to punt this job to a
shady group of misfits like the
guardians we may never know
egos relationship with mantis director
James Gunn wanted a sequel to include
some characters from the comics that
didn't make the cut the first time
around and mantas who has a long and
storied history with guardians was an
obvious choice but to fit her in gun had
to tweak her story so in the movie she's
basically an indentured adopted daughter
to ego using her empathic powers to help
him sleep at night
wait what ego is an ancient powerful
celestial being and he needs an empath
to sleep at night how did he sleep in
the thousands and thousands of years
before
anthis came along and why would he let
her the only person who knew his true
intentions hang out on chaperone with
guardians where she could spill the
beans at any time well whatever
maybe ego just can't manifest a supply
of ambien the way he manifested an
entire planet and maybe his godlike
status made him a little overconfident
about his nefarious plan but most
importantly maybe we're so psyched to
have mantis in this movie that her
backstory doesn't really need to hold up
to scrutiny
who's your Hasselhoff in this film we
learned the quill keeps a pic of Knight
Rider era David Hasselhoff in his pocket
because as a fatherless kid he used to
tell people the Hoff was his real dad a
subplot that leads to this
crowd-pleasing cameo from Hasselhoff as
one of egos various avatars there's just
one problem
this Hoff is a senior citizen whereas
quills aspirational dad was the
strapping young Hoff of the 1980s in the
context of the story and for maximum
emotional impact on Quilt ego should
have appeared as that version of
Hasselhoff but if that was going to make
the difference between working with the
Hoff directly versus recreating his
younger self using CGI it's not hard to
see why the filmmakers prefer the real
thing the truth about quills mom ego is
still making a hard pitch for quill to
join him when he also spills a
horrifying secret he's the one who gave
quills mom cancer a fact he reveals to
his son while also trying to woo him
over to the dark side but for some
strange reason learning the ego is
responsible for the worst trauma of his
life doesn't make quill feel like
teaming up with him and I'll come so
predictable that any celestial being
worth his salt should have seen it
coming and equally inexplicable is why
ego bothered to off quills mother at all
what gives dude I returned earth to see
her three times and I knew if I returned
a fourth
I'd never leave that's his story but we
don't buy it everything we know about
ego suggests he's a raging sociopath who
doesn't care about anyone and since he's
planned all along to kidnap quill from
Earth taking mom out of the equation
seems pointless plus ego has been alive
for millions of years so what's the big
rush why not just be happy for 40 or 50
years and then complete the master plan
once she dies of old age or something of
course this is still an important moment
in terms of establishing ego as a
cut-and-dry bad guy and giving quill a
good reason to want to destroy him but
it's one of a handful that doesn't make
narrative sense no continuity for old
Marvel the timeline of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has always been kind
of fuzzy but guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 represents a real missed
opportunity for MCU continuity here's
the deal
egos attempt to take control of the
earth occurs around the same time as
films like Captain America Civil War and
the ABC series agents of shield
surely the MCU stop crime fighters would
have noticed the giant tide of alien goo
engulfing half of Missouri and a
crossover cameo in either direction
would have really helped to tie this
universe together
sadly egos incursion on earth never
earned so much as a nod in these other
Marvel properties and in guardians to no
other MCU characters ever showed up to
investigate the goo situation the
invincible Milano we all know that
star-lord has a very cool ship the
Milano is fast slick comes loaded with a
tape deck for all your soundtrack needs
and makes a hell of a mobile mancave
find a black light
please look like a Jackson Pollock
painting but is the Milano literally
indestructible the ship takes a pounding
during this battle with the sovereigns
forces in which dozens and dozens of
ships fire point-blank on the guardians
yet star-lord ship weathers threw all
that damage when other ships have gone
down with just a shot or two how does
the Milano survive this veritable
onslaught of laser fire while still
maintaining enough integrity to stumble
toward a crash landing in this case the
answer is simple flawed armor the same
reason why stormtroopers have such
terrible aim and James Bond can somehow
win a fistfight with the henchmen twice
his size
if one direct hit could knock the hero
ship out of the sky there would be no
movie thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to check out
all this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]